Putting some numbers behind this,
the dynamic range that the human
eye can deal with is incredible.
It ranges over 14 orders of magnitude,
and there's almost nothing
in the real world that works over
14 orders of magnitude, right?
So that means 10 to the 14,
one and 14 zeros times
from the darkest dark to the brightest
bright that you can deal with, and
by the way, that does include looking,
like, directly at the sun, because,
frankly, you can't actually see much
when you look directly at the sun.
It's too bright.
All right?
But you can go from somewhere from 10
to the minus six to 10 to the eighth,
what's called candelas, which is
a unit of energy, per square meter.
It's a measure of the amount
of the flux of the light, and
flux falls on a particular area.
So, the human eye can
set its dynamic range,
its set point, to anywhere from this
really low, this 10 to the minus six,
10 to the minus five, 10 to the minus
four, so that'd be a range of two,
up to 10 to the six, 10 to the seven,
10 to the, another range of two.
It can set it anywhere
along that spectrum.
At any given point in time, it's
operating at at least a hundred to one,
maybe a thousand to one, maybe,
maybe even more than that.
It depends upon how you're doing.
And in any given sort of real world
scene, like I was just showing you,
the actual ratio of sort of the darkest
area to the brightest area,
can sometimes be in
the order of 100,000 to one.
Right?
So you're standing there,
it's really bright outside,
it's kind of dark in here,
that difference might be under if,
if it was that far, even your eye
would have difficulty dealing with it.
But it's way better than
most imaging systems.
Now, the thing is,
everybody knows about your pupal, right?
When it's bright out the pupal closes
down, when it's light you know,
when its, dark, the pupal opens up.
That's a very small range of variation.
A colleague of mine,
professor actually, used to say that it
was like an order of 10 to 100
variation, in terms of the size.
He actually said 10, but
I think it's a little smaller than that.
But how do you do the this
great huge variation?
Well, it's actually the retina's
ganglion cells that make this happen.
And the way it does it is, and
this is sort of looking at just a single
section, so remember, light's coming
in this way, not too important for the,
here we have our photo receptors,
here we have our horizontal cells,
our bipolar cells, Amacrine, and
then there's these ganglion cells.
But notice that this thing is referred
to as the surround, the center,
and the surround.
And you can think of this as being
a slice through a circular operator,
okay, and that circular operator
would look something like this.
Okay?
In the retina, they are refered to as
center-surround receptive fields, and
what that means is, that in the positive
ones takes the illumination that's
from the middle, and they subtract
off the illumination around the back.
The negative ones do the negative in the
middle and subtract, and add, positive.
But basically what they're
doing is they're comparing
the local illumination to the,
a little patch of the illumination
to the overall illumination.
So what happens when
things get much brighter?
Well if it's just getting
brighter over the whole thing,
not a lot different changes.
So one part of your retina can
be sort of electrically and
chemically setting its dynamic
range at one place, and
another part is at another
place simultaneously.
So the part that's looking at
the bright window in the church
is operating at one place.
The part that's op, that's looking
at the the darker part, it,
it, it's doing its center-surround
on a darker area, but
it's looking at those
relative contrasts.
This plot here is just a notion of what
a center-surround field looks like.